insane asylum
man crazy lunatic of some of the terms
apply to people who have lost their man
they used to be called God's food
medical idealists allege that it was the
possession of a man's soul by vicious
passion and so to purge the soul they
tortured the body
so it was in the early 19th century
but even at that time materialist said
there was no such thing as a so they
maintained that insanity was a disease
of the brain Iran the session of the
founder of the Russian school of
physiology and later the great scientist
even a blog investigated the functions
of the human brain and nervous system
the ascertain that all psychic activity
stems from reflexes
this is an unconditioned research during
his lifetime nan also develops a great
variety of conditioned reflexes
the reflex is a form of bonds between
the organism and its environment
this person is mentally helped it not
only the prick of a needle but even the
sight of it stimulates a reflex
but how does the mentally deranged
person reaction the disease rain does
not respond to external irritation the
organism has lost contact with its
environment
the psychic phenomena were first studied
by Vladimir victory a progressive minded
man of science and a material
he made an enormous contribution to the
science which deals with the structure
and functions of the human brain
bacterias applied the signs of
conditions or as we call them
combination reflexes to the study and
treatment of neuroses and psychoses
his pupils and followers on the staff
will be psycho neurological institute
founded by bekhterev are continuing the
humanistic traditions of russian
medicine for promoting the health of the
people
a new patient let's trace it
which will follow him into the Institute
to see what the doctors and scientists
began to do to bring him back to sanity
a grave misfortune has befallen valerian
panic yet
he has lost the power of understanding
where he is and what happened to him
here's the suit by terrifying monstrous
images
can sanity be restored the conscious and
the other patients
I tear like a wolf or the throat of
bureaucracy down with routine and rapey
and effective but look those verses are
not yours they are they are may
accosting but may cost us died long ago
yes but I wrote them in 1930
you're still living Oh June so how does
May across the counter I'll explain
he was my son you also wrote poetry and
used my students he died for lyrical
reasons this patient in that event the
new ones complete her
are you a composer - yes what have you
written I written ten Shostakovich
symptomless
all of Shostakovich his symphonies are
mine some of the coffee of compositions
are mine - every mental illness has its
causes associated with a patient's
character his upbringing and the joys
and sorrows he has gone through it is
necessary to know all this before
beginning a treatment it's better to get
the story from the patient himself
medicine now has means of temporarily
restoring the patient's consciousness
you've got the Christmas well how do you
feel
we're Emma in a hospital applause yes
you are not feeling well here why were
you sighs why didn't you eat anything
they throw back to his day I don't know
they're not around anymore
don't worry everything will be all right
we'll cure your own
the talk with furniture was the
psychiatrist
later he questioned the patient's
parents and relations
very good
tanika's mother told the doctor that his
son lived in many red when he was 14 and
suffered all the horrors of the blockade
hunger cold in bombarding he was
shell-shocked and before the war was he
an ailing child yes it was a weak boy
easily susceptible to sickness
could it have been the ailments of
childhood that deranged furnitures mind
was that the cause this hallucination
perhaps so there may be other we the
patient spring related the following
incidents two years ago when he and
venereum were returning together from
work a car coming round the corner
almost over Anna child but Ariane the
rush decided it was in time to push the
boy aside but was knocked down by the
cars fender
the psychiatrist is not the only person
concerned with the well-being of each
patient the Institute's researchers and
physicians and the laboratory staff help
to identify the disease detect the
organic changes that has caused and
devise methods of treatment
it is not easy to make a diagnosis nor
is it easy to treat a mental disease
especially in his early stage the
patient used the doctors actions as a
threat to his life
there is primitive applied in the
Institute Sanchez is medicated with
Amina zine epileptics are treated with a
bekhterev compound in combination with
other remedies insulin shock and other
modern methods are applied to
schizophrenic
the treatment goes on for weeks
seldom does a mental disease are they
suddenly
all of these markings fit into the
health restoring head this department is
for treating neuroses Nina
Yemaya neva suffers from hysterical
paralysis of the right arm the rest of
etter of every disease is moral
depression when the patient loses heart
as well as hope of recovery bekhterev
attached much importance to
psychotherapy the psychotherapist must
find the source of the ale explain it
and restore the patient's good chair and
confidence in recovery
you know the cause of your paralysis no
is it nervous trouble yes you've guessed
Rogers too young but why should the
nerves of a young woman like you be in
disorder
what do you think if it's be with me
that way before since childhood
it's the consequence of wrong upbringing
of pantry codling arranges the
nervousness and every issue you had
always been guarded from trouble and
when it did come your nerves capitulated
rest assured that we will cure it today
we're going to start treating you by
hypnotist your arm will be active again
eat it
Vicky just always really bleed blood out
leaving your mortgage you're highly
negative with drowsiness they have
closed and you cannot open your device
seclusion which you sleep in a corner
now you're calm do you ever get or arm
is gaining strength with you well now
let it drift with your and it will stay
raging Ohio
maybe she keeps you move your way or
perish what do you say nearest allow you
is the power of motion is coming baby
when you awake your arm will functional
fit provision
what's your nature what color short very
good would you get you're on the road to
recovery
bekhterev developed the theory of
hypnosis and applied it for the
treatment of nervous and mental
disorders meet Salma one two three
if nurses applied in the Institute today
for individual and group treatment of
alcoholism and other disease conditions
you now feel repugnant for butter for
wine and all other alcoholic beverages
we roll weight with an aversion to
alcohol sleep sounder
after weeks of treatment Nina Emilia
Nova works almost as deftly as other
patients since sector it's time the
doctors have been describing manual work
as a totem therapeutically agency
special workshops have been opened for
this purpose
whether the unconscious also continues
his treatment
let him in victory I've introduced a new
branch of medicine neurosurgery for the
treatment of nervous diseases by
surgical operation
what brought this man's the
neurosurgical clinic the presumption
that he has a brain tumor presumption
however is not sufficient ground for
being such a delicate operation
modern instruments trace the curve of
the brains electric currents yes there
are electrical phenomena in the human
brain
they were discovered and studied by dr.
Victor is back in the old days when
there were no such sensitive instruments
present-day radio and television
techniques afford an opportunity to
probe into the brain all doubts now be
dispel the findings have confirmed the
diagnosis
an x-ray of the brains blood vessels
shows the exact location of the tumor
now the surgeon can apply the scalpel
neurosurgery has saved thousands of
lines
the operation was successful
the vestiges of the tumour will be
destroyed by x-ray
here again is Nina Emiliano she
completes her course of treatment with
radioactive barrels and other physical
methods the physical methods applied of
Institute are based on victories ideas
of treating nervous diseases by reflects
cell therapy fresh confirmation
objectives ideas have been found in an
ancient curative method of Chinese
medicine treatments by needle pricks and
cauterizing is another good remedy
and so having completed our round of the
psycho neurological institute we shall
leave it together with furniture the
doctor reminds him that he should visit
the narrow psychiatrist affinity
business and one more reminder panic
chef should abstain from alcoholic drink
would you
with Suzanne you look
every day the department's of interviews
send home people from the doctors and
scientists have restored sanity and
healthy
let him in victory the doctor scientist
and prominent public figure was a man
filled with a capital F he lived and
worked for the sake of restoring sanity
to the instinct of promoting the health
of mankind
Moscow on a late afternoon in summer
city streets crowded with workers
businessmen wives and soldiers anxious
to be home and meet with friends the end
of another working day in another city
but underlying the bustling activity is
a quiet perseverance a perseverance
which might not understand but which has
learned to accept hardship
the knowledge that other nations enjoy
higher standards of living is seldom
remember and even to a stranger like
myself seem far distant Russians have
nothing to regularly remind them of the
absence of luxury good things they would
like to have the camp of what should be
but in during my summer travels in
Russia I found myself greeted with a
warm curiosity an easy hospitality
chatting as best I could with people in
the streets and visiting them in their
home
I found myself caught up in an aura of
national there seemed to be a general
lack of self identity of a confining
self mindedness
the explanation of this attitude is not
difficult the Russian was simply too
busy to think about themselves and as a
consequence have lost the introspection
which used to be considered a Russian
characteristic
mental illness in Russia is not a common
topic of conversation when asked about
the comparative low incidence of mental
disorders they explained in a
matter-of-fact manner but this can be
attributed to their social equality
these two workers are standing in front
of the walls of a psychiatric hospital
this hospital and others like it has
100,000 beds in Russia not enough to
meet the country's need the Oviatt
mental hospital in Moscow has 600 beds
mental care comes free and only the
seriously ill will get treatment
here are the oldest a psychiatric
hospital devotes itself to the care of
1,000 inpatient outpatient clinics such
as V Odessa psycho neurological clinic
is by far the most care they offer early
diagnosis helped keep workers on their
feet and out of the hospital whenever
possibly
this is the public psychiatric hospital
in Kiev I have just entered the ground
without escort and without notifying
anyone beforehand the atmosphere is one
of relaxation and informality patients
are not required to wear a uniform and
if well enough control languidly in the
afternoon side
this woman is visited by her husband
though not enough hospital those which
do exist like the Pavlov Hospital have
enough personnel according to dr. Balian
chief of Psychiatry for the Soviet Union
there are 4,000 psychiatrists in the
hospital each psychiatrist average is a
patient load of 28 at the Pavlov
hospital these psychiatrist average 20
patients each the most surprising
statistic is that over three-quarters of
the doctors or women
a warm personal interest is shown by
these lady physicians toward their
patients I would say a woman's touch in
addition to psychiatrist there are 320
psychiatric nurses to care for 1000
patients at this hospital in the average
Russian mental hospital each nurse takes
care of six patients a fully qualified
nurse must complete three years of
special training after high school
adequate numbers of personnel
tranquilizers and sedatives make
straitjackets unnecessary and in fact
illegal in the Soviet Union the Russians
have a long history of humane treatment
for mental patients a custom which
started long before the Bolshevik
Revolution I think that every hospital
administrator the world over has a test
project he wants to be completed here
the objective was to replace the bars on
wards housing the violently disturbed
with unbreakable glass windows this
gregarious individual is diagnosed
manic-depressive Russians used the same
diagnostic labels as we do and as we do
they consider each patient an individual
case Lilya wringing of hand points up
this woman's anxiety syndrome
what is made the patient sanction
conflict with the factory supervisor
here police crowded living conditions at
home these and other reasons became
apparent during my conversations with
patients however I soon discovered that
Pavlovian theory which dominates Russian
psychiatry does not emphasize social
causes as the source of mental
disturbance
with us in mind I journeyed to this
Louviere mental hospital and clinic in
Moscow the see how psychiatrist actually
diagnose and treat patients here at the
clinic these children were waiting for
news of their brother in the next room
he's receiving a neurological
examination if the problem is deeply
psychological the why behind the
disorder is not brought to the surface
not measured by psychological tests not
analyzed by a Freudian theory as the
conscious did Salafi has told me you
Americans are more on theory than we the
doctor traditionally begins treatment
with a complete write-up of the medical
examination in case history for an
alcoholics and psychotherapy and
sedatives but not the analyst count for
an epileptic the same drugs is used in
America hospital records show that
epileptic make up eight or nine percent
of the hospital population a
schizophrenic receives sleep therapy and
insulin shot electric shock is
officially regarded as a brutal form of
therapy and therefore is used
infrequently patients diagnosed
schizophrenic comprise 25 percent of the
country's total hospital population
a victim of syphilis has arrived for
treatment arsenic compounds will be used
instead of penicillin which is still
hard to get into fishing quantities
patients with syphilis to the brain
comprise about two percent of the Moscow
hospital population
according to the Russian in all of the
Soviet hospitals the rate of recovery
average is ninety two point seven
percent of arrivals and 61 percent of
combined arrivals individual patient
these percentages refer to those
patients who are considered recovered
enough to leave by the end of the year
as you can see syphilis carries the same
social stigma in Russia as in the US
these fifty year students of Socotra
told me how they were trained to be
psychiatrist after high school they
received a medical education of six
years and are taught almost exclusively
Pavlovian theory in Russia the emphasis
is on neuropsychiatry the scientific
study of enter and interpersonal
relationships is definitely played down
in importance basic Pavlovian theory is
used by the russian relates not
primarily to behavior or environment or
mine but to the brain students rely
therefore heavily on drugs and on a
russian specialty called sleep therapy
dr. shovel nova only 25 years old has
placed electrodes over the eyelids of
the patient and set the control to 10 or
15 milli amperes she will maintain the
sleep for one hour electric sleep rather
than shock is commonly used for
depressive patient
work therapy and supportive therapy go
together
the Russians feel that useful activity
develop wholesome social attitude
attitudes which psychiatrists analyzed
by what they call common sense not the
psychological tests or Freudian analysis
Freud supposedly over emphasized the
role of sex and instinct officially
branded in Soviet Russia as
philosophical idealist
the psychiatrist listens sympathetically
to the patient's problems and then
prescribes medical treatment or advice
for her to follow the basic gain in
treating her is to restore the patient
to good health and to the community
Russian do not strive to get the patient
to understand his whole mental life to
gain deep insight and understanding
their fear satisfied to get the
patient's back on his feet
there is no doubt that dr. casaya is
effective and sympathetic and the doctor
with the heart but one cannot help
wondering whether or not training in
depth psychiatry would make are still
more effective psychiatrists can get
most patients back on their feet through
chemotherapy but what about the actual
roots of the disturbance
dr. Josiah keeps children active at play
our children's ward has 25 patients
serious cases involving epilepsy brain
tumor and brain damage at birth
so these emotionally disturbed children
life is kept as normal as possible here
we see a classroom biology being
conducted in the hospital itself
the Salovey at mental hospital and
clinic marks the end of the three-month
tour in Russia as a parting gesture dr.
nebula invited me to visit her little
boy Sasha whom she calls for it is nurse
Lee at the end of each day it struck me
that the motherly affection she showed
Sasha he's the same basic interest in
concern that she and others like her
have shown their patients at the various
hospitals I visited during the summit
although there is a basic dissimilarity
between Pavlovian theory and the
concepts of Freud which has had
widespread influence in the West
Russian psychiatrists even though they
function in a different ideological
sphere have one thing in common with
doctors all over the world
they want their patients to get well as
quickly as possible
to restore them once again to the
society they live in